in the village where they called the
queen a neighbor there was a quiet
ceremony to it all the park and ride for
those taking flowers to Balmoral the
small meticulous details of a transition
they knew would come but dreaded all the
same
we were here in the shop last night we
just
broke down completely both my wife and I
they saw a different Queen here and
remained grateful she called this place
home it's a it's a loss of a friend and
a neighbor that we feel as well as a
monarch
boo you know we hear a lot of what I
hear a lot of people talking about the
end of an era
but we have a new king already and I
think it's the start of a new era across
the road the butcher who made sausages
for the family barbecues John Sinclair
saw the queen only three weeks ago for
this area it's a massive massive blue if
the queen arrived in ballot there was
you know like the boys went around the
village or the Queens in the Queens in
the town but nobody bothered them they'd
maybe they'll look out the door as well
the queen tell where she went and then
enter car and I'll be back up to my
model again and nobody wanted her the
streets of balita are always busy at
this time of year drawn by the Royals in
Residence
in Braemar a new arch in her honor but
one she never saw she'd been coming to
the Highland Games here since her
childhood watching from the patrons
Pavilion
the game's president a Game Keeper by
trade like everyone here with his own
memories I think one day when we were
out gross shooting up in
berkalbi state and she got to run up
onto the high tops and she looked back
down Glen Clooney to bremar and she was
just struck with a site she'd never seen
it from that a direction before and it
completely meshed her she said it was a
beautiful part of the country to be
I think I'll never forget that they are
Greg Milam Sky News Braemar